[Musique]
il est 83 et vous êtes bien sur RMC et
BFM TV bonjour François Bayrou merci
d'être dans ce studio ce matin pour
répondre à mes questions vous êtes au
commissaire aux plans vous êtes
président du MoDem vous êtes maire de
Pau on va revenir d'ailleurs aussi sur
la décision du parquet hier qui a
annoncé qu'il souhaitait vous renvoyer
devant un procès vous et 12 autres
personnes du MoDem pour détournement de
fonds publics mais je voudrais d'abord
vous interroger sur ce qui s'est passé
hier et sur la sortie de ce qui
ressemble de plus en plus à un bras de
fer installé dans le pays une
mobilisation qui reste très forte 1,2
millions de Français dans la rue une
accélération deux journées de
mobilisation par semaine à partir de la
semaine prochaine le 7 et le 11 février
une opinion publique qui tous les
sondages le montrent et de plus en plus
hostile à cette réforme et puis de
l'autre côté un gouvernement qui dit
qu'il ne négociera plus en tout cas sur
l'essentiel et qui reste extrêmement
ferme comment on sort de ce bras de fer
comment on sort de ce qui ressemble de
plus en plus à une impasse le sujet
principal c'est ce que vous avez dit
c'est à dire une partie de l'opinion une
partie très importante majoritaire dans
les sondages qui ne se reconnaît pas
dans cette réforme
et elle ne se reconnaît pas parce que on
n'a pas partagé avec les Français les
raisons véritables de la réforme tout à
l'heure j'entendais la représentante
dessus qui était sur votre plateau et
qui disait un sentiment d'injustice
c'est précisément pour la justice qui
qu'il faut qu'une réforme soit
construite
chacun y entend ce qu'il veut et
d'ailleurs il est plus tellement utilisé
par le gouvernement peut-être à tort
aujourd'hui la situation que nous avons
l'ambiguïté de la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes
c'est que un certain nombre de
responsables
font croire croire ou font semblant de
croire que les retraites sont
équilibrées que ça n'est pas nécessaire
ce n'est pas urgent qu'on a tout le
temps pourquoi on fait une réforme la
vérité des chiffres que nous avons
établi avec un rapport au plan que tout
le monde peut trouver sur plan.fr la
vérité de cette situation c'est que
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui et depuis de
très nombreuses années les retraites
sont déficitaires écoutez bien de 30
milliards d'euros par an 30
000 millions d'euros chaque année 30 000
millions d'euros chaque année
justice et on a précisément l'impression
que dans ce débat sur les retraites il
n'y a pas de vérité des chiffres alors
certes dans vos papiers du plan sans
doute mais le corps par exemple lui-même
a reconnu que il y avait différents
scénarios
suivant qu'on soit optimiste que suivant
qu'on soit petite exactement là qu'est
le loup comme on disait autrefois parce
que le corps qui a été institutionnalisé
comme comme portant la vérité pour les
Français le corps a fait un choix qui
est vous allez le voir extrêmement
discutable pernicieux le corps dit
nous ne tiendrons plus compte des
déficits actuels les 30 milliards dont
je parle
c'est déficit là on les considère comme
acquis et tous les ans le gouvernement
fournira le même montant
ou le même pourcentage de mon temps par
rapport aux produits du pays
et il ne s'intéresse où il ne mesure que
les déficits à venir pourquoi on entend
des chiffres comme disent 12 milliards
mais vous voyez bien que c'était 30
milliards que nous fournissons tous les
ans plus ce qui vont venir en fait ce
que vous nous dites 30 milliards ils
sont déjà dans le sable quoi pire que ça
si c'était dans le sable ça pourrait
aller cet argent que l'État fournit tous
les ans si on l'avait bon ça serait
discutable on pourrait dire voilà on a
un pays qui produit plus c'est un choix
on va financer les retraites mais cet
argent nous ne l'avons pas et c'est là
qu'il injustice majeure c'est-à-dire
laissez-moi finir ma phrase parce que je
pense que c'est très important et que si
ceux qui nous écoutent
pensent que là et la vérité alors
quelque chose peut bouger dans l'opinion
publique cet argent nous ne l'avons pas
et pour le verset tous les ans qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on l'emprunte
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait payer les
retraites d'aujourd'hui
par les actifs de demain
et donc ce sont les actifs ceux qui vont
rester au travail plus les jeunes qui
vont arriver qui vont avoir la charge de
payer ces dizaines de milliards d'euros
par an et ceci n'est pas
évidemment les prix sur les vrais
dépenses d'investissement qu'on devrait
faire
on sort d'une période d'abord on sort
d'une période qui a épuisé les Français
qui les a même laissés sidérer il y a eu
le covid il y a aujourd'hui l'inflation
il y a la guerre aux portes de l'Europe
et puis il y a eu quoi qu'il en coûte
pendant quoi qu'il en coûte tout le
monde pensait qu'on n'avait pas d'argent
comme vous le dites et puis on s'est
rendu compte quand on en voulait
vraiment on en trouve donc pourquoi on
en aurait trouvé pour le quoiqu'il en
coûte et que là maintenant on dirait ben
non ça c'est pas
une raison extrêmement simple d'abord ça
ne peut pas durer quand vous avez un
pépin dans une famille
quand vous avez un pépin dans une
famille vous faites un effort et c'est
tout à fait naturel et puis après ça
revient en vitesse de croisière si j'ose
dire mais là la question c'est que dans
pendant le quoi qu'il en coûte on
pouvait emprunter à zéro pour cent
les taux d'intérêt étaient à 0 et quand
vous empruntez à zéro aussi avec cet
argent vous faites un peu de croissance
depuis
les taux ont triplé
quadruplés un peu soudain ils sont à 3
et vous voyez bien que ceci n'est pas
soutenable ce n'est pas durable quand on
voit qu'il y a eu 240 milliards d'euros
pour le quoiqu'il en coûte et que
maintenant pour les 30 milliards on nous
dit c'est plus possible il y a plus rien
vous comprenez ce n'est pas 30 milliards
c'est 30 milliards de déficit
les retraites
de retraite c'est 345 milliards par an
l'État sur ces 345 fournit 143 milliards
c'est-à-dire 40 % et les déficits c'est
30 milliards et donc de ce point de vue
là les chiffres que je donne ils sont à
la disposition
cette réforme et vous dites au fond la
même chose qu'Emmanuel Macron quand il
dit que c'est indispensable et que il
n'y a pas le choix maintenant le
problème c'est la situation avec cette
France qui est dans la rue qui n'a pas
l'air de vouloir
essouffler la mobilisation qui prévoit
de nouvelles journées et de l'autre côté
en effet le gouvernement qui reste
extrêmement ferme qui va craquer le
premier est-ce que comment on sort de ce
bras de fer
il va y avoir un débat au Parlement
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat vont
voter j'espère que ce débat sera utile
c'est-à-dire qu'on pourrait approfondir
un certain nombre des décisions prises
en matière de justice ce sont des 64 ans
quand vous écoutez Laurent Berger c'est
ça qui a mis le feu aux poudres Laurent
Berger avec la CFDT qui était prêt à
soutenir la réforme version 1
c'est-à-dire la réforme par point qui
aujourd'hui fait évidemment partie des
opposants lui il dit si on ne retire pas
la question des 64 ans il n'y a pas le
reste ne sert à rien c'est le 60 est-ce
qu'on peut renégocier les 64 ans
François Bayero je pense que si on
abandonnait la réforme alors on se
trouverait dans une crise
d'opinion dans une crise politique il ne
pourrait pas y avoir une allongement de
durée de cotisation mais on supprime la
question de l'âge vous savez bien que
c'est la même chose si vous allons si
vous allongez la durée de cotisation
vous reculez l'âge c'est la même chose
le gouvernement a choisi d'avoir les
deux signaux et pour une raison qui
existe vraiment c'est à dire que
le problème du fait que on ne puisse
plus trouver de travail à partir d'un
certain âge vient de ce que la société
tout entière s'est mise dans la tête
qu'elle soit 60 ans c'était fini il y a
un problème de rapport au travail il y a
un gros problème de rapport au travail
je vais vous en dire un mot mais si on
met un signal âge qui n'est plus à 60
ans mais à 62 ans mais qui alors on
augmente comme tous les pays autour de
nous l'ont fait le comment je peux te
dire l'image
des de ceux qui sont au travail de
celles et ceux qui sont au travail et
qui
on va y revenir mais dans le débat tel
qu'il s'est installé vous faites partie
de ceux qui aujourd'hui dans l'entourage
du président ont un peu de mémoire
politique davantage en tout cas que ceux
qui sont au gouvernement quand vous
voyez la manière dont le débat s'est
amorcé avec l'accusation de
ceux des opposants avec l'accusation à
Laurent Berger d'être irresponsable
était une bonne manière d'engager le
débat franchement ce genre
d'affrontement c'est la c'est la plus
mauvaise manière d'engager le débat
quand on est dans des confrontations qui
sont des conversations des
confrontations
blessantes enfin de mise en cause
personnelle vous n'auriez pas dit ce
sont des paresseux
pour une raison précise c'est que je
pense qu'il y a une question de rapport
au travail qu'il faut prendre au sérieux
c'est pas de la paresse c'est ça je
pense que
cette attente de la retraite comme une
période de délivrance ou miraculeuse
elle vient de ce que
le travail
et
ne correspond plus à ce que ne
correspond plus souvent à ce que les
gens attendent qu'il y a de l'usure
qu'il y a de la routine qu'il n'y a pas
d'horizon qu'il n'y a pas de changement
de perspective qu'il n'y a pas de
nouvelles responsabilités
je pense qu'il faut éviter les
vocabulaires qui sont excessifs
je pense que les Français n'ont pas été
suffisamment informés mais on peut pas
dire aujourd'hui de un mois après que
les Français
que ce n'était pas clair
derrière ce que je défends il y a une
certaine idée d'une nouvelle pratique
démocratique en France une pratique
démocratique qui est capable je le crois
de de changer l'état d'esprit des
Français de changer l'esprit de public
considère non pas comme on fait depuis
des décennies et je presque dire siècle
que une fois que quelqu'un est au
pouvoir
c'est lui qui prend les responsabilités
il suffit bien que ce soit le sommet qui
connaissent les réalités il décide et
les citoyens subissent ça n'est pas ma
conception de la démocratie
c'est on considère les citoyens
l'hôpital public l'opinion civique comme
j'ai l'habitude de dire comme des
partenaires on leur donne tous les
éléments on ne se réfugie pas
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas c'est pas
le cas et vous voyez bien
il y a eu du mépris en tout cas des
expressions que vous n'auriez pas choisi
mais vous voyez bien que ce que je
défends c'est précisément un nouveau
modèle politique on fait comment
c'est-à-dire que quand on a l'opinion
publique qui est dans ce sens-là
faudrait-il par exemple est-ce que ce
serait une des portes de sortie
envisager un référendum alors vous me
prenez par les par les sentiments parce
que depuis 20 ans j'avais défendu cette
idée je c'est que pour éviter les
blocages c'était une solution
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas la voix que le
gouvernement choisi vous voyez bien que
ça supposerait qu'il y ait des remises
en cause et des et sans jeux de mots des
retraites mais au sens militaire du
terme qui est pas la solution
aujourd'hui si vous étiez aujourd'hui au
pouvoir vous diriez attention on fait
pause et on envisage éventuellement à
faire de pause je ne dirais pas une
pause je dirais je dirais donnons la
parole s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
partagez avec les Français les raisons
qui font que la situation a atteint ce
point d'irréversibilité mais maintenant
si on est pas les 64 ans on négocie quoi
il y a les seniors il y a les femmes il
y a la situation des femmes j'ai défendu
je défends l'idée que il faut que les
années de maternité
soit
assuré de ne pas coûter de ne pas être
handicap pour les femmes et pour la
retraite des femmes et aujourd'hui il y
a sûrement des éclaircissements
une question de trimestre validé mais
aussi une question de légèreté
valorisation vous voyez bien la petite
nuance que vous avez introduite les
trimestres sont validés mais ils ne sont
pas considérés comme cotisés donc il y a
forcément une perte donc il y a une
gagne en âge niveau de la retraite et
si c'est confirmé parce que c'est très
compliqué comme vous le savez je vois
vos yeux c'est très difficile d'entrer
dans le dossier sur des sur des sujets
comme ça mais si on clarifie ça par
exemple en disant voilà nous apportons
la garantie que les années ou les
trimestres de maternité seront pour les
femmes des trimestres qui ne leur
coûteront pas c'est la moindre des
choses
penser aussi financièrement et pas
uniquement en termes de temps on
pourrait aller plus loin en disant que
ça pourrait être bonifié
ça fait partie de ce que vous mettriez
sur la table ce que je mettrai sur la
table c'est une politique démographique
ça n'est pas possible que nous
acceptions que nous continuons à subir
une situation de chute démographique
pour le pays
alors que
la France ne peut exister son sa
vitalité économique et son contrat
social ne peuvent exister que si nous
avons une démographie vivante que si
nous avons renouvellement
que nous avons
renouvellement de génération et donc ce
ce travail là d'une politique
démographique probablement retrouvant
des
des situations qui ont été abandonnées
sous le gouvernement sous un
gouvernement précédent
que les allocations familiales n'étaient
plus universelles donc on a nous avons
au moins mettons cette phrase dans notre
esprit nous avons à construire une
politique démographique qui soit à la
hauteur de ce que le pays attend donc
cette réflexion sur la revalorisation
aussi des pensions des femmes est-ce que
vos députés modem vont voter ce texte je
crois oui oui il y a pas de doute il y a
pas de doute il y a
un autre individualité qui dit que il
hésite mais moi j'ai bon espoir que tout
le monde viendra le député du Loiret
Richard Ramos qui dit qu'il hésite vous
allez être je pense que
des éléments peuvent lui être apportés
mais ce sont des démarches individuelles
et je parle d'un groupe de plus de 50
députés qui est je crois le plus soudé
de tous les groupes de la majorité vous
allez sans doute être jugé François
Bayrou c'est le journal Les Échos qui
l'a révélé hier dans son réquisitoire
définitif rendu lundi et après 5 ans
d'enquête le parquet de Paris demande le
renvoi du parti le modem et d'une
douzaine de ses responsables devant le
tribunal correctionnel pour détournement
de fonds publics 12 personnes plus vous
13 donc qui pourraient être jugés dans
l'affaire des emplois fictifs
d'assistant parlementaire d'euros
députés après 5 ans d'enquêtes voilà
leur décision vous continuez à estimer
que c'est faux mais je vais vous
apporter des preuves
comme vous le dites ça fait 6 ans
d'affaires a démarré au mois de mars
et au bout de 6 ans
qu'on se retrouve dans une situation
comme celle-là vous avez dit emploi
affectif
dans tous les documents fournis par les
magistrats il y a une phrase qui dit il
n'y a pas d'emplois fictifs
ça change quand même considérablement
les choses il n'y a jamais eu par
l'Europe et bien ce n'est pas vrai qui
travaillait pour le n’est pas vrai et
c'est une
épreuve ont été apportées il y a eu des
jugements de la Cour
d'appels
mais il y a ensuite d'autres étapes et
notamment la décision du juge
d'instruction je vous dis ceci nous
n'avons jamais
utilisé ces procédés là chez nous tous
ceux qui étaient assistants
parlementaires de députés européens
avaient un contrat à temps partiel pour
le député européen et à temps partiel
pour le mouvement
et la cour d'appel a dit que ceci
suffisait pour prouver que c'était réel
et vrai et pour le reste
l'ensemble des preuves que nous
apporterons montrons aussi que ceux qui
nous ont accusés et c'est dans le
jugement de la Cour d'appel c'était des
adversaires politiques les gens qui
avaient profité de ce mouvement et qui
après s'était retourné contre lui comme
hélas arrive lorsque les gens sont
médiocres et donc cette cette certitude
c'est une bataille politique je vous dis
simplement un petit mot regardez les
partis politiques qui sont mises en
cause le Parti communiste français
les insoumis le Front national quelle
est la caractéristique de ces quatre
mouvements
sont tous des mouvements minoritaires et
quand vous êtes minoritaire comment
défendre vos positions si vous n'avez
pas de partie politique mais qui aurait
intérêt
la vie politique c'est une jungle
et assez souvent vos adversaires les
bêtes fauves qui vous agressent se
trouve pas nécessairement dans le camp
de vos ennemis il arrive
oui mais
après il y a des épisodes donc il arrive
parfois que la jungle vous réserve de
mauvaises surprises
pour répondre à votre question mais
cette François
est faux y compris dans leur chiffre
mais on le montrera on va pas faire les
politiques est-ce que non je veux je
veux pas employer ce genre d'arguments
parce que
ça vous a quand même coûté le job de
ministre de la Justice précisément mais
vous voyez c'est pas ça la question
principale
la question principale est que dans ce
genre de de piège il y a des gens qui
supportent qui ont les épaules pour
supporter qui ont le cuir épais pour
supporter
et d'autres qui n'ont pas cette solidité
là et qui tombe malade et parfois qui
meurent vous évoquez Marielle donc il y
a évidemment dans ces affaires-là une
dimension
d'agression humaine qui est difficile à
porter ça n'est pas pour moi
c'est que Marielle de Sarnez est morte
c'est parce que je laisse entendre je ne
connais pas une seule personne qui la
connaissait qui puisse dire le contraire
c'est comme ça la vie vous savez
il y a des gens qui sont de ce point de
vue là du point de vue de l'honnêteté
fragile du point de vue de l'image c'est
très grave
je parle le sentiment de dire quelque
chose de léger oui
nous avons vécu ça
dans une équipe humaine ou des liens
sont extrêmement forts
c'est extrêmement
difficile à porter oui bien sûr vous n'y
est en tout cas toutes ces accusations
François
la preuve
président du MoDem maire de Pau